some consider Thomas Edison one of the
greatest inventors ever Edison was
photographed next to a light bulb so
often that people came to believe he
invented it but he didn't several
inventors had already demonstrated
various versions of incandescent lights
before Edison patented the first
commercially successful light bulb
Edison never crafted something out of
nothing his genius lay in his ability to
craft something better to perfect what
was already available his critics say
his only real invention was taking
credit for the inventions of others so
was he America's greatest inventor or
was Edison a thief
you decide
Edison's life changed when he was 15
years old one day when he saw a station
official's young son playing by the
tracks in the path of an oncoming train
Edison rescued two-year-old Jimmy
McKenzie before a train crushed him the
boy's father was deeply grateful and
Todd Edison had to operate Morse code on
a telegraph machine this was not easy to
do operators had to quickly send out
signals in dots and dashes which were
converted into letters that made up
words and phrases Edison began working
full-time as a telegraph operator in
Michigan where he grew up and later
traveled around America working at
different offices for years he was able
to do this even though he was moderately
deaf he then decided to devote himself
to a life as an inventor well actually
he mainly improved upon what was already
invented in 1874 he developed an
advanced version of a telegraph machine
that could send and receive four
Telegraph messages simultaneously on a
single wire two in each Direction his
quadruplex Telegraph machine enabled his
former employer Western Union to save
money because the company could now send
more messages without having to build
new lines Western Union purchased the
rights to the invention for ten thousand
Dollars around 260 000 in value today
Edison used the money to build his great
laboratory at Menlo Park New Jersey he
began by perfecting the telephone there
by 1876 Alexander Graham Bell had found
a way to transmit human voices over
wires the telephone was revolutionary
Western Union commissioned Edison to
improve upon Bell's invention to make it
practical and so Edison worked on a
telephone transmitter while working to
perfect the phone he also tried to
record the human voice the phonograph
put Edison on the map giving him the
nickname The Wizard of Menlo Park he
began to expand his Factory and his
appetite for more inventions his big
breakthrough came when he created a
successful incandescent light bulb as I
mentioned earlier others had already
been making light bulbs British inventor
Joseph Swann obtained the first patent
for a light bulb in Britain two years
before Edison patented the bull
meanwhile in America William Sawyer and
Alvin Mann had received a U.S patent for
the incandescent lamp in 1878. so what
did Edison do he improved the bulb
previous versions had only been able to
work for a few minutes at a time by
October 1879 Edison had an aha moment
his bulb with a carbonized filament
burned continuously for 14 and a half
hours but that still wasn't good enough
for him he and his assistants tested
thousands of plant materials and finally
came up with a filament made from bamboo
that could last up to 1200 hours
in 1880 Edison received a historic
patent for an improvement to Electric
lamps it's been debated whether Edison's
patent infringed on Sawyer in man's
previous patent eventually Edison's
American lighting company merged with a
Thompson Houston Electric company which
made incandescent bulbs under the Sawyer
man patent together they formed General
Electric
on New Year's Eve 1879 Edison lit up New
York's Christie Street marking the dawn
of the electric age this was at a time
when the world still relied on
candlesticks he then began to mass
produce and sell them but he didn't stop
with just improving the light bulb
Edison then began working on building a
system to carry electricity so people
could use his light bulbs in 1882 he set
up a large generator plant on Pearl
Street in lower Manhattan and lit the
street with electricity he became rich
and famous and ruthless like when he
tried to discredit a rival form of
electricity
Edison's generating system used direct
current which has its flaws DC travels
through a power line in One Direction at
a constant voltage but can only go up to
a mile or so before losing power so a
generating plant was required every few
blocks he hired a young engineer to
improve upon his DC generators but
Nikola Tesla came up with a better
solution alternating current
AC periodically changes Direction and
can also vary its voltage it can travel
hundreds of miles without losing power
yet when Tesla tried to convince Edison
of the advantages of AC his boss wasn't
having any of it Edison didn't want to
lose the royalties he earned from his DC
patents
Tesla's AC system caught the attention
of American industrialist George
Westinghouse who bought up Tesla's
patents AC generators were spreading
fast across the country faster than
Edison's DC system
so in order to discredit his Rivals AC
system Edison devised an ugly strategy
he gave boys who lived around his New
Jersey lab 25 cents for every stray dog
they brought it an organized public
electrocutions of these dogs Edison took
every opportunity to question the safety
of Tesla's AC system declaring just as
certain as death Westinghouse will kill
a customer within six months after he
puts in a system of any size Edison
secretly funded the first electric chair
which used AC despite publicly
denouncing capital punishment the state
of New York had commissioned his former
assistant Harold Brown to build the
chair Brown pushed to have it powered by
AC using a Westinghouse generator that
he surreptitiously secured through
another company but his schemes didn't
work AC would go on to power the world
much to Edison's dismay yet Edison was
more famous than Tesla and certainly a
lot wealthier
I've done a series of videos on what led
to Tesla's tragic demise which I'll link
to in my description
I've been patented a whopping
1093 inventions in his lifetime he
managed thousands of skilled scientists
machinists and designers who researched
developed and manufactured new
technologies so where did Edison's Real
Genius lie as Graham Moore writes in his
novel The Last Days of Night about the
feud between Edison and Westinghouse in
Tesla his genius was not in inventing
rather it was an inventing a system of
invention dozens of researchers and
engineers and developmental tinkerers
labored beneath Edison in a carefully
constructed hierarchical organization
that he founded and oversaw in other
words Thomas Edison may not have been a
genius inventor or a thief but a Savvy
businessman who had a knack for managing
people
it was his shrewdness as a manager that
allowed him to turn laboratory
discoveries into technological Marvels
in the marketplace even if many of the
original ideas came from someone else
regardless of how you feel about Edison
his contributions have undoubtedly
changed our lives whether you're a fan
of him or Nikola Tesla what they both
had in common was a firm grasp of math
and science if you'd like to improve
your stem skills to invent the next
great thing or simply to better
understand the world brilliant is a
website and app where you can learn math
science and computer science
interactively I know my viewers
particularly love their scientific
thinking course in this exercise you
have to make the bridge as rigid as
possible with as few beams as possible
another course popular with my viewers
is their pre-algebra course where you
can strengthen your math skills in a fun
way where it doesn't feel like learning
if you ever get stuck you can click the
explanation to to see where you went
wrong brilliant is great for those who
are in school and also for those who are
already working I personally use
brilliant to help improve my critical
thinking skills you can dedicate a few
minutes a day to improving your stem
skills by relearning the basics or
having fun with their more advanced
courses and it's free for you to sign up
with a custom link in my description
brilliant.org newsthink in the first 200
people who sign up with my link will get
20 off Brilliance annual premium
membership which gives you unlimited
access to the hundreds of courses they
offer thanks for watching for a news
think I'm Cindy Palm
[Music]